hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday March 20th
2023. what's going on how are you
oh man
it's been a glorious couple three months
off
and it's all coming to a close but you
know what I'm not going to do what I did
as a kid
when summer vacation was ending and you
just start counting the days down going
like only 11 days left I gotta go back
this is gonna suck you know and that was
always like a one brief
moment of excitement when you went out
and you got some new clothes for school
you know how it worked back in the day
was you got you got a pair of sneakers
that were like at least a size too big
that you were eventually going to grow
into
and those were your sneakers for a year
and uh there really wasn't that I don't
know
sneaker it was really simple back then
they was like there was white sneakers
and they had a red stripe a blue stripe
a black stripe
it wasn't until 86 when uh the first
Jordan came out which I'll be honest
with you I thought that was the ugliest
[__] sneaker I'd ever seen in my life
I thought it was absolutely
hideous
that in nine million other things I was
wrong about as a kid
um well I still know I'm still not
really the biggest fan of that one I
like the style of the Jordan one but not
the original
colored one
um anyway
yes you have that brief excitement that
you get some new clothes and then yo
said the excitement of seeing your
friends
and uh all the pretty ladies you know
see who was in your class hoping you'd
have a good class he'd get some class
clowns in there you could [__] joke
around
because she didn't want to be there
we used to get in trouble all the time
and they would [__] uh I remember one
year
there was four of us
then we were having such a good time the
teacher had to prevent it from happening
you know what are you enjoying
yourselves
so
you know those like four or five rows of
kids probably eight rows
you know there's always like 35 40 kids
in a class
so she had us all sit at Each corner
like I sat first row front desk
then my other Class Clown Buddy was in
the same road last desk
and then the other one we sent all four
corners is basically where she put us
thinking that that would stop but every
time she turned around I just couldn't
see the dude behind me
but I still remember looking this dude
Brian rest his soul
he was [__] hilarious and his thing
was he knew how to make the fart noise
with his hands he didn't have to go
under his armpit you know what I mean he
could just he could [__] go
he would do that but he would really and
he would squeeze it out and make it
sound like a fart
and uh the teacher could figure out
where it was coming from and you know
I'm in the third grade all right you
make a fart noise I mean that's like
that's Richard prior to me at that age
so
oh oh and we the desk got moved around
and there were notes
and all of that [__] why am I talking
about this because I feel like this is
the end of my adult summer vacation
getting ready to go back out on the road
but I'm also excited I am uh totally
rested up
um I feel like I have a cold or
something I don't know what the [__] I
got I've been fighting this thing off I
haven't been sleeping well
lately and uh been holding down the fort
here with the kiddos been having a great
time with them
um
and I've been watching a bunch of match
Madness I worked actually watched the
first couple of days my bracket has
disintegrated
you know the two teams that I love the
Kansas Jayhawks Indiana Hoosiers they're
out of it
there goes two [__] conferences
I don't even know who the hell I had I
know versy's got Tennessee they're still
in it
is that Ivy League school Princeton's
still in it please still be in it still
please still be in it what did they lose
they're in it oh they're in it
Princeton's in the south
here's one for you this is how you know
how you did in high school when you have
no idea where Ivy League schools are
I know that I know a few of them just
because they were in my state Harvard's
in Boston
and then Brown was in Rhode Island
and then years later I learned that
Dartmouth
was also in New England
there's one in New York City
oh Princeton's in New Jersey right
there used to be a a
holy [__] I did a gig out there a long
[__] time ago
the late great Vic Henley
that was a good gig
oh my God I haven't thought of that in
forever anyway Princeton's still in it
the [__] smarty pants
who says mathletes can't [__] hoop
um
I got this song in my head
I got a song I'm in my heart I can't
[__] get this song out of my head
let me get my [__] chest X-rayed I
think when I got pneumonia still got
fluid left because I can't stop [__]
hacking up I don't even smoke anymore
oh I got rid of all my cigars everybody
[Laughter]
[Music]
got rid of all of them brought him down
to The Comedy Store they got a humidor
down there I just put them all in there
I had like boxes
of cigars I couldn't even fit them in
the humidor what's Ward got out that I
smoked
[__] I go on the road hey welcome to
[__] Peoria is a [__] box of
cigars
I'm not gonna lie to you it was
fantastic
and uh thank you to everyone that gave
me those cigars but it just got it got
out again I had like enough cigars here
to start my own store
so I finally was just like all right I
gotta get this [__] out of you and I
said it to you guys I was getting that
[__] out of here and I'm looking over it
they are all gone
except for this box of 25 Cubans that
somebody gave me those I kept and those
are in my humidor in my bedroom and I've
had them though
for nine days and I haven't smoked any
of them
and I look at them
and I like them
and they smell good
but I just keep saying to myself you
don't want to do that
you don't want to do that wait till
there is an event
invite a bunch of people over
and hand them out and then they'll smoke
most of them and I'll just have one
that's what I do there's 25 there so
what I need to do is invite invite seven
people over to smoke with me
three times and then there'll be one
left and I'll only smoke four of them
is this even a podcast anymore like what
am I talking about I'm looking at my
[__] bookshelf
anybody want a book huh
giving them away and finally admitting
to myself that these books that I've
read I'm not going to read again
and uh they got these things around town
here in LA
we uh
you just donate books and people come
walking by and they leave a book and
they take a book
I know where there's like three of them
I'm gonna start dumping my books there
like three four at a time
it's gonna be funny too because my book
I you know I my book my books are like
for morons
you know what I mean
and there's probably like you know
classic books that people are dropping
off like uh
the [__] Piglet and the bird whatever
those [__]
one of those classic books these for The
Prince and the popper
right
Turks and Caicos I can't literally no
The Count of Monte Cristo
it's all I got um and the rest all I
have is [__] rock autobiographies
that's it I've already been through my
bookshelf I'm not doing this again but
I'm getting rid of all of that [__]
um
do you guys how stupid is that someone
like me that I don't read and I actually
have a bookshelf with books on it I mean
what am I doing
that's like having signed football
jerseys and [__] up on your wall and you
can't throw a ball
oh wait do I have one up there I don't
no I don't
oh good I got [__] I got a scared
recently recently just now I gotta scare
what the [__] again I still got a bunch
of [__] I I got a bunch of cigar
paraphernalia I have to get rid of
um I have like 9 000 lighters 9 000
Cutters uh they're all like refillable
so I don't want to throw them out
because they're plastic and they're just
going to go in the ocean float around
for [__] 900 years so
um
if you come out to my show and you want
a lighter just ask me I'll bring them
with me and I'll just start I'll hand
them out I'll hand them out like a uh
like one of those people on Instagram
that tries you know that shows what a
good person they are by making an
Instagram video about what a good person
they are
maybe you see people if you're seeing
these things where people go on they
make an Instagram video of them helping
out people
I mean I guess on some level you're
inspiring people to do stuff like that
I just think it's funny that you go out
and you not only do you like you help
somebody but you got to film it and then
put like Sad Piano or or um string music
underneath it
um
that's another thing people do like when
they uh
there's always just some [__] idiot
like me running his Yap
and when they're trying to give you life
advice if you notice those [__] uh do
you ever notice I'm really going 80s
comedy on you guys today
that they always [__] have they got
to put this music underneath it
like if you're really giving me good
life advice it should be able to stand
on its own right why are you scoring
your opinion
calling up [__] John Williams
and then you always got to have the
other person
sitting across
like someone on an infomercial
I never looked at it that way
that is fascinating
yeah we know it's fascinating we can
hear the fascinating music that they're
playing underneath your fascinating
point oh I am in a mood today
I'm in a [__] mood
what is going on with Val you know life
life [__] happens you know people you
know what happens when you become an
adult
is you constantly you got to be the
bigger person
[Laughter]
that it is a thankless job
uh just be the bigger person
go over there and do this you know don't
do that don't get involved in that you
got you gotta be a bigger person
uh what are some of the other adages
they'll appreciate it
tell it they'll look you know when they
get older they'll appreciate it you know
that [__] it's all like down the line
it's like trying to get paid by a record
label
next one next album next album comes in
that's when we give you your [__]
money
um
but anyway
I've gone for I've gone like oh for 32.
I think oh for 48 how many
however many games they've played in
this basketball tournament I don't think
any of my teams Alabama I had going
San Diego State I had losing to
Charleston
um
did I pick Baylor I probably picked
Baylor just because I saw a three next
to him
uh
uh I picked Arizona they lost
Jesus Christ I mean I just [__]
all right who's left
Creighton's left I know I didn't have
them I know I didn't have Princeton I
had Alabama I didn't have
San Diego State University all right so
I went one for four in the south
Florida Atlantic
they're the 31-3 team that was actually
for real
who did they beat
wait Purdue got beaten by Farley
Dickinson
Jesus what the [__] was I
Duke got beat by Tennessee
all right that those numbers all match
up I didn't have any I might have had
Tennessee but I think verzie did
Kentucky Michigan State I had nothing in
that bracket I'm now one for four people
I I had Houston I didn't have Miami
definitely didn't have Xavier and I
definitely didn't have Texas went one
for four again
Jesus Christ this is like me back in the
day multiple choice
test
I had Kansas so Arkansas blew that up
that was a great game by the way uh I
didn't have Yukon
I didn't have Gonzaga I had UCLA oh I
got two one no I got one in that one oh
my God
Jesus Christ
man I must have been blindfolded just I
mean I didn't watch any games this year
Bill what the [__] did you expect oh all
right
all right then just be the bigger person
you know just try to be the bigger
[__] person
um
you know who never was the bigger person
everyone in jail
can't say everyone but a lot of them
went out and did what you fantasize
about doing I wonder why they never made
a documentary on that
you know what I mean
like the amount of times okay
somebody has done something to you and
you want to be like you know what you
know I I would love to just go up and
[__] you know beat the [__] out of
the throw a chair and throw a glass slap
him in the face you know do something
like you just don't do it you're like
well I can't because I'll get sued I'll
get arrested but
you know
people in jail don't have to [__] sit
there going you know what I should have
slapped that guy
they probably sit there going like I
shouldn't have slapped that guy should
have been the bigger person
you really can't win
oh my God I don't think I've ever been
clearer in my life that I don't believe
in God
you know I don't I do believe you should
be a good person and and
that type of stuff but not because
there's some invisible guy who's gonna
get upset if you don't because that
person just clearly
clearly
does not give a [__] or is just totally
bored just the way this game has been
set up
that you know
turning the other cheek is the way to
hold on to what you have
if you actually do or say what you
[__] think more times than not
you end up paying for it
you know doing the right thing versus
choosing more money never choosing the
money never is never the right thing
it's unreal
pizza and ice cream make you fat
brussels sprouts keep you skinny
it's just I don't understand
I gotta say I really respect
an obese person
that's walking around slapping people I
mean that I think there you're you are
living your best life
I like pizza I'm eating it I like ice
cream I'm eating it I don't like what
that person said about me I'm slapping
them in the face
the big trans fat hand
you know
it's [__] waterlogged
with cholesterol
um
[Applause]
you know it's just not worth it you know
you get in a relationship with somebody
and you just have to just you know
you know it's about compromise
um
I'm all over the map here um anyway so I
always give
you know my my kid a ride to school
right
and she has this song that she listens
to
and whenever it gets in my head I I
can't
I can't get it out but what's funny
right now is now I want to sing it I
can't remember it and I shouldn't sing
it
oh there it is oh it's back
it's like Batman
join the fun Squad
you know super positive it doesn't
matter if it [__] rains you something
something and it goes away to paint come
and join the fun Squad oh
mindless
and she loves the song and I love the
look on her face when she listens to it
so I play it every day and then I walk
around
for like
the better part of the morning with that
[__] song in a loop
jumped out of bed and something in
something
come and join the fun Squad
foreign
you know there's a formula for that
like they got it like corporate people
that like
just sit in a [__] office
and they have an algorithm that they
plug into a computer and they go what
notes
will just like
turn into like a sideways tornado and
just float into your inner ear and just
stay there and spin around in your
[__] head
until you finally give in and buy the
song
um all right I realize this this is a
little dark
I've gone through a lot of [__] right
now people
you know
it's one of these [__] times in life
you just go through a lot of [__] and
then you just try to get to the other
side
oh that's it live life out loud
above the crowd you can't choose to be
happy come on join the fun Squad
I love that they say you can choose to
be happy
you know I'm waiting for [__] people
with clinical depression to say that
they find that line offensive
you know if being happy was just a
choice but I'd be sitting here putting
my face into a radiator
uh we're sorry sir we didn't realize
that you were clinically depressed when
we tried to make a song to make children
happy and give them a positive outlook
about their life but by all means
let's [__] stop the song and let's
address you in your life
your unfixable life
um that's a good name for a show the
unfixable life
um oh Billy freckles is going back out
on the road
he's back
he's back in the saddle again all right
I got some new
some new dates
Cohen I didn't sleep last night sorry
May 5th
2023 I'm in Las Vegas Nevada at Dolby
live
May 5th
uh September 29th 2023 I'm in Portland
Maine
at the Cross Insurance Arena
Cross insurance so they get insurance
for Jesus there uh September 30th 2023
I'm in Manchester New Hampshire
at the snhu arena
so New Hampshire University Southern New
Hampshire University maybe is that what
it is
I'm gonna go with that for 500.
um
I've almost had a cold for like three
days
I keep taking this [__]
that like holds it at Bay
but it doesn't knock it out
it's like when Bone Crusher Smith fought
Mike Tyson he just kept holding on to
him throw a few and then he just tie
them up throw a few and just tie him up
um bomb Crusher Smith one of the
scariest
[__] looks on on on on a boxer's face
walking into the rink used to make his
eyes all wide and grit his teeth and
just looked like he was absolutely
[__] crazy
um
all right artist pre-sale is Wednesday
March 22nd at 10 A.M local time
I still don't understand what that means
like local time all right so if you live
on the west coast you live in Hawaii
you gotta wait to 10 a.m your local time
is that what it is while everybody on
the East Coast buys up all the tickets
why would they do that
oh I'm an idiot
10 a.m Vegas time you'd go to the Vegas
show you're not gonna try to buy the
Manchester New Hampshire ones wow
I want to say that that was a bit it
wasn't all right
10 a.m local time I finally figured it
out
Thursday March 23rd at 11 59 PM local
time oh that's when it is from March
22nd at 10 A.M local time to Thursday
March 23rd at 11 59 pm
uh local time the code is Burr b-u-r-r
the General on sale is Friday March 24th
at 10 A.M local time
all right
what do I do now do a little advertising
here what do you say what do you say
there I started to watch an F1 race last
night I didn't realize they were already
on the second race of the season
um I was going to try to watch a little
bit of that I'm just focused on the Moto
GP because I'm going to the third race
this year down in [__] Austin Turkish
I'm very excited about that
the [__] is my email here
all right I'm gonna get funny at some
point here in this podcast right now
you're just hanging out with me
um all right zip recruiter oh look who
it is it's old zip
I also realize how thin these walls are
my neighbor could hear me when I'm
screaming I gotta stop doing that uh you
was you uh if you were to start a new
business what would it be examples a
taco truck business
a bouncy castle backyard party business
I can tell you those are two businesses
I would never think of starting I don't
know how to make cooked taco meat
I don't want to stand in a truck while
drunk people come up to me and say that
I [__] up their order
a bouncy castle backyard parties I just
bunch of [__]
kids draining out of their nose animal
rescue shelter there you go
some kind of charity
that's what you should call it too
uh all the proceeds from tonight's show
goes to some kind of charity
selling handmade wood products
all right those are that's yeah pretty
much covered it there are three flavors
of iced tea grim leafer
rest in Peach an armless Palmer
liquid death's new Iced Teas are
available now with free shipping on
Amazon and retailers near you as an
added bonus Monday Morning podcast
listeners get 20 off their first liquid
death apparel
uh
um purchase available exclusively at
liquiddeath.comrr exclusions May apply
that's liquiddeath.com
okay
oh look who it is everyone it's butcher
box butcher box
you know cooking at home is important
and so is having the best quality food
to do it
well yeah I mean that's
it's pretty obvious
do we need to say that
cooking at home is important well maybe
some people don't know that and so is
having the best quality food you mean if
you have the best quality food it's
gonna taste better that's exactly what
we're saying over here at butcher box
butcherbox provides you with the best
meat and seafood on the planet
so you can whip up quality meals on the
butt on your budget man they're talking
a lot of [__] here on the planet
better than a five-star restaurant yeah
I go [__] though you don't want to go
over there
three Michelin stars they could shove
them up their ass we got the best meat
and fish I like this butcher but I like
the new aggressive butcher bucks
100 grass-fed beef organic chicken
pork raise crate free
they let those [__] pigs run around
before they they're giving up a cut well
they dropped a hammer on them
wild caught Seafood you don't know what
they're gonna do
humanely raised no antibiotics or added
hormones before they kill them
get just what you need delivered right
to your doorstep free shipping
see butcher Parks pretends they like
their pigs before they kill them
so they're nice and relaxed and that's
why they're delicious and I stand by one
of the best pork chops I ever had was
from these guys free shipping for the
Continental UA and it doesn't surprise
me because they have the whole the best
[__] meat in the planet
it's like a wrestling promo uh free
shipping for the continental United
States and no surprise fees what the
[__] is this
choose from a variety of books that was
somebody being surprised on a fee
how was your day honey oh it's great I
got some mail I like your hair what the
[__] is this
honey you gotta stop doing those
outbursts oh the hell with you
uh choose from
choose from a variety of box plan
options from curated to customized and
change your plan whenever you want get
free chicken nuggets for a year
chicken nuggets like McDonald's wait a
minute I thought we were doing the help
oh they must just cut them like that
this is their chicken that chicken gets
to run around free chicken nuggets for a
year and get 10 off your first box when
you sign up today that's a 22
ounce bag
of gluten-free you don't [__] get
caught by the cops carrying all that
chicken
try to catch me a riding dirt at it 22
ounce bag of gluten-free chicken nuggets
in every order for a year when you sign
up at butcherbox.com
slash Burr
and use code Burr
um and then for some reason the diet the
the the
copy is now vertical
claim this
deal at butcherbox.com and
use code Burr
that was like a [__] eye to the
longest eye chart ever and it was just
one lane all of that was like stacked on
top of itself like a skyscraper of
letters
all right
okay we're back to the podcast I wish
you guys could have read listen to that
last read I had to do a dynamic read
that's a read that I don't know I guess
it's a makeup read for something else
these [__] [__] it should be it
should sound friendly clear calm and
reassuring not like a laugh as being
stifled
and it says introverbatim
and it's about erectile dysfunction so
evidently they haven't been appreciating
my jokes
you know why does it have to be so
serious they have a solution
a bunch of humorless cons
you know how do you sit there working
with flaccid dicks all day and not have
a sense of humor about your [__] job
that's what you're looking at all day
I think it's great that you're out there
helping people but you know you can't
[__] laugh about it
oh God you know
maybe maybe the world just isn't a fun
place anymore
I mean what [__] world are we living
in that I'm talking about medicine for
you dick that actually works and I have
to I have to do it in a serious tone
I mean if we
[__] laying there like a flounder
what am I supposed
all right come to Newfoundland New
Newfoundland
all right hey Billy Ginger tits
um yeah you keep complimenting me like
that I'll be on the next flight uh in
light of our recent show announcement in
light of your recent show announcement
in Halifax Nova Scotia I wanted to bring
this up as a long time listener of the
podcast I heard you say numerous times
you've got you've done all of Canada
from Vancouver all the way to the east
coast and Halifax well I live in St
John's Newfoundland
which is even further east than Nova
Scotia
in fact we are the most easterly point
in North America well Jesus I won't have
to take a [__] tour of this town
with all of these these all this
information you've given me oh yeah
what's what's your [__] bird
what's what's the state bird up there
the province bird we have a capital city
of around 200 000 people this is [__]
amazing
I wish more people would do this when I
was going to their town this is our
population here's some fun sights to see
now that I don't drink and I don't
[__] smoke cigars
to drink coffee oh God
what happened
you know what happened bill you had too
much fun that's what happened
you used up all your fun days
now you just have to sit around do
nothing and wait to die
um oh Jesus that was dark we have a
capital city of around two hundred
thousand with a great downtown scene
with a seven thousand seat Arena right
next to the most famous nightlife Street
George Street
person is hooking me up
would be great to see uh would be great
for you to come check us out and have a
show St John's is very similar looking
to Boston or Dublin with a big Irish
background and a lot of funny bastards
living there well I gotta tell you you
sold the hell out of that
St John's I learned a lot of [__] in
there that I already forget
you live in St John is that the capital
of Newfoundland that has 200 000 people
and a 7 000 seat Arena
that's a lot of tickets to sell in
Newfoundland
I've never been there I thought which is
the one that has like the the outside
oval one of those places out there right
me and verzi skate they had an outdoor
like a public
almost like a speed skate skater track
Eric Haydn would go around remember that
how the [__] did that name just pop in
my head
um
but it was like a public skate I mean it
must have been like it was like a
quarter mile track
maybe they just flooded it they probably
did that they flooded it and I got on I
go oh my God this is the most amazing
thing ever
and I did like one lap of it and I was
like I'm [__] exhausted
um it was also snowing up
um
so the ice wasn't that good
um but there's the excuse you were
looking for Bill does that make you feel
better that you can't skate a quarter of
a mile without being exhaust exhausted
anyway so if you can muster up the dad's
strength to swing down after your
Halifax show that would be incredible
incredible P.S [__] the Bruins Go Leafs
Go
um all right well
I don't know why you hate us oh I guess
I know why
you did have his beat in that playoff
series I was at that game too
yes I was
shouldn't you really be saying [__] your
front office I mean how many goddamn
years are you gonna go without winning a
cup
you guys I'm 50 I mean 55 years old in
June
the Leafs have not won a Stanley Cup
in my lifetime
I think that's a little bit of
misdirected anger there sir
um anyway all right solar system oh boy
hey Bill a month ago or so you talked
about the solar system I talked about
the solar system
okay flying through space while rotating
I said that
I can't back that up with any fact
whatso I'm sure I said it
wasn't like it
it's still expanding from The Big Bang
or something I don't I always start to
watch those things
and then I I just can't handle them
after a while it just gets too big for
my little brain to handle
you know
that's why I'm always Neil deGrasse
Tyson is suspect to me
because it's like he shouldn't eat
wouldn't he be like [__] just
absolutely tortured talking to someone
like me
like this guy understands how the whole
universe works
and I'm down here I can't even fill out
a March Madness bracket to the [__]
sweet 16 and not have most of my teams
out of it
right
like even that just that I would compare
what he knows to that I would think
would be enough to make him [__] want
to get up and walk out of the room
yeah he does it all the time he's always
talking
to people that aren't scientists
foreign
oh my God you're so [__] smart but
it's like we're all dumb
right
so that's my thing with that guy I I'm
holding out on whether that guy's smart
enough I want to hear another scientist
say that that guy's smart and he's not
just spewing out a bunch of [__] that he
read in a science book
um
right
does that guy invented anything has he
changed the way we look at stuff
or is he just reading science books and
then saying it to someone like me who
only reads autobiographies of rock stars
I have no idea or is he a smart guy and
it just makes me feel insecure and not
like myself so now I'm lashing out at
him there's a lot there's a lot going on
here people
all right
solar system hey Bill a month ago so or
so you talked about the solar system
flying through space while rotating that
already sounds like whatever I said
there was wrong that little animation
made the rounds a few years ago but was
eventually broken down by physicists as
not the most accurate representation
I love that you feel like I actually
think about this [__] I don't even know
why I said it I probably was just
riffing about something anyways there's
a lot more math involved apparently who
figured here's a link
this is at bigthink.com
starts with a bang slash our motion
through space isn't a Vortex but
something far more interesting
you know what I'm going to leave that
heavy thinking to other people I'm not
I'm not
oh my God should I do it should I click
on it
all right I clicked on it open the link
oh my God here we go
my chest is already getting tightened
it's tightening up here all right listen
to this article
they already know how many dumb people
are coming here pretending to be smart
listen we know you don't like to read
uh maybe we could just listen to it
um would you like to listen to science
on tape
get smart on tape
for 19.99 you could sell that late night
are you tired of saying things at a
party and
the conversation stops and
whatever circular end gravity just
becomes a circle of one as people slowly
peel off
wouldn't it be great to go to a party
and say things that made people's
eyebrows go up
like wow I never thought of that well
you can do it now
with soundsmart on tape that's right
each month you would get it you're going
to get a tape where a bunch of people
spew out smart facts that you can then
say at a party
and then maybe you can convince some
woman to breed with you and you can make
a little dumb [__] kid uh one of the
most popular
because you got to think that guy's a
[__] and what whatever woman was dumb
enough to not realize that he was just
spewing out smart facts she has to be an
idiot too
and unfortunately two negatives don't
make a positive
when it comes to making a baby if you
got two morons your baby's [__]
and you can ask Neil to grasp Tyson
about that
okay
you could even ask even his brother
probably knows that one uh
one of the most popular viral videos
about space is dead wrong but it gives
us a chance to learn something
incredible
oh that was really [__]
that was really [__] uh
what do the kids say there was a lot of
shade in that huh one of the most
popular viral videos about space is dead
wrong but it gives us a chance to learn
something so incredible I like how they
just buried that in there
and then they went went positive real
quick super passive aggressive
you guys don't know what the [__] you're
talking about you got your [__] heads
up your asses and this is such a great
opportunity to learn something
wait a minute did you just tell me go
[__] myself about a half a sentence ago
I don't know what you're talking about
uh there were a lot of moving parts to
the universe
I love that this website big think is
already realizing that morons like me
are going to read there are a lot of
moving parts to the universe
as nothing exists in isolation all right
the water's getting colder I think we're
getting into the deep end here there are
literally trillions of large masses in
our solar system
large masses of what all orbiting around
the galactical Center on a time scale of
hundreds of millions of years but
there's a viral video part one and two
that claims that the solar system moves
through the Galaxy it makes a Vortex
shape pulling the planets behind
behind it as it does
but our true Cosmic address in our real
Cosmic motion is far more complex and
interesting than a mere model such as
this Jesus Christ can you [__] on those
last people anymore
it's a little more complex than their
[__] remedial diorama that they came
up with which is fascinating
because it's all governed by one simple
law general relativity and I'm out
I'm out
theory of relativity
it's all relative all of that [__] that
word uh oh my God that word in this word
meta
someone's going to explain it to me
again hey hey
big bad Billy badass meta is a fun
concept to dive into when it comes to
entertainment
all right this is one of those words I
was talking to Joe bartnick the other
night
we really should have recorded the
conversation is both of us have had the
word meta explain to us numerous times
and we still don't quite get it
because the definition it's it's it's
when something is commenting on itself
like when I go like oh my God I
Jesus Christ look at me I I need I need
to iron my shirt is that meta
my I'm talking about myself right I know
it's not that
commenting
I was talking about myself commenting
about
I think Bill is really missing alcohol
does that matter
I'm just commenting on myself
put simply meta breaks the fourth wall
and shatters the suspension of disbelief
by simply stating the actual reality of
what is happening
Oh you mean like hipsters
breaks the fourth wall shatters the
suspension of disbelief by simply
stating the actual reality of what is
happening
another way to phrase it is meta just
simp just means the actual actors or
performers as themselves
simply commenting on the reality and
truth of what is actually going on for
example thank you thank you thank you
for an example
because that's usually where it stops
me saying I'm writing an email to Bill
Burr's podcast right now
is technically meta
okay in your stand-up comedy special
paper tiger you went Meadow when you
noticed your mic clip fell
off the stand and you mentioned that you
needed to screw
it back in back on for continuity
that's meta
that's not just like stating the obvious
like I don't understand
did they just come up with this [__]
word so you could just sound like he's
yeah he's talking about what he's doing
That's So Meta
all right
this just seems like an extra step in
the English language that doesn't need
to be happening I feel Anyway by
mentioning the my clip and continue and
continue
in continuity you called attention to
the reality that this was a filmed
comedy special
you are you are actually a performer
performing
and that the special would be edited
requiring continuity
had you not mentioned the mic clip or
had your editors just cut around the mic
clip mishap and cut out you bringing
attention to it it would have maintained
the suspension of disbelief for us
watching your special on Netflix that
the entire routine happened the way we
saw it
so if I didn't say that people wouldn't
have known that there were edits despite
the fact that we're cutting from one
side to another and
you know all of a sudden you're at the
back of the Arena
all right so look okay I think I get
that I get that now so look at that you
went meta and didn't even know it thanks
for always making my life seem a little
less shitty go [__] yourself this is me
ending my email and that was meta
okay
so like being honest about a moment is
kind of like being meta
let me look at this again
you know what I'm smoking and you
mentioned that you needed to screw it
back on for continuity no I no I had to
do that
what I was doing was I was addressing
what was going on which is page one of
stand-up comedy
and then I had to put that back on and I
had to make it funny
so I was just imitating
like the direct I was still performing
stand-up comedy is what I is what I
thought I was doing evidently oh look at
me I was being meta
all right well you know something I
thank you that's the best way that
somebody has
um
explained it
I do find it hard that if I didn't say
that that
people watching at home wouldn't have
realized that they were watching a
stand-up special
and that it was edited I kind of find
that hard to believe but I guess
I guess I get that uh fed renovation
dear Bill did you know that the FED
Federal Reserve had office Renovations
in Works in 2019 the budget was 1.9
billion dollars
but due to inflation it's going to cost
2.5 billion
can you imagine the shoulder shrug in
the accountant's office when they heard
that
I wonder they'll let me use the bathroom
since I helped [__] pay for it
wait that Federal Reserve building you
know the Federal Reserve is had office
renovations
it cost that much money wow I mean you
could build a [__] sports arena for
that amount of money but you know they
do control the money supply
hey good for them
food for them I bet it was a lot of work
printing out all that money
um
that's funny they didn't print it out
they had us [__] pay for it
God damn it I have to go see a [__]
doctor man
hacking up a lot
hacking up a lung
woke up packed up along got the car had
some [__] fun come and join the mucus
crowd
yeah I guess I do have a little bit of a
quote but like this [__] since I've
had pneumonia it hasn't gone away and I
don't smoke anymore so like what is
going on maybe it's just all the evils
just coming out of me
oh no what did I what have I done here
what is going on with my podcast oh [__]
I got two different bands going here
because I hit pause earlier so you
didn't have to listen to me hack up ah
[__] who knows who knows come on join
the fun I'll let I'll let Andrew figure
it out
um
adoption dilemma hi Bill
long time fan here from Southern oh
southern Ireland really enjoy your
comedy and your advice for listeners
here's my situation ah God loved me I'm
51 happily married three great kids
Etc all good however
I was given up for adoption when I was
three years old when I was just a weak
hunt
all right
you get on for adoption with when you
were three weeks old a few months ago
the Irish government changed the laws
and gave adopted people access to their
birth records for the first time ever
holy [__]
long story short I've just found out
that my birth mother is alive in Ireland
and I have two half brothers and a
half-sister uncles aunts Etc none of
whom know I exist
and Jesus Christ she's got to be
sweating bullets now huh
my birth mother doesn't want any contact
with me and never told anyone about me I
was told this by Irish Social Services
well maybe she's changed over the years
I don't know
I mean at this point you're 51 it's not
like she's got to [__] support you my
dilemma is whether or not to reach out
to my siblings and run the risk of
rejection
or potentially ruining their family by
giving away my mother's dark secret from
back in 1971.
it's Weighing on my mind a lot as I said
I have a good life but I feel like
something is missing now that I know
these people exist they live about one
hour drive away oh my God advice would
be appreciated love the podcast keep up
the good work thanks
um I wouldn't go to anybody other than
her
I would go to your mother
and
I would talk to her and then just see
where she is with it
um
I can just say personally if I found out
that uh I had a 51 year old half brother
at this age time in my life I mean I'd
be like oh
didn't know that like all right
but I wouldn't look at my mother
in any sort of way or anything I'd be
like well it must have happened when
something was going on in her life and
uh I'm sure it caused her a lot of pain
and you know I don't know but I don't
think I wouldn't like rip apart my
family like Mom how could you not tell
me that you didn't have somebody else
but it is I feel like um
more of a respectful way not like you
owe her that
I don't think but like uh
yeah I would go I would go through the
mom
just show up
hiya whatever the [__] you guys say over
there
is that English
hiya
um
Excuse Me Miss
yeah I was uh
remember that baby you gave away when it
was three weeks yeah
how you doing
guess who
foreign
I mean how do you even go about that I
mean uh this look at this is above my
pay grade I would ask somebody uh
I'd ask somebody to Pub I wouldn't ask a
[__] therapist about this I don't
know why
they're just gonna make it a lot longer
and arduous you know just being like you
know there's a lot of
different things and emotions when you
know try to drag it out into seven
sessions so they can make some [__]
money
um I would go out I would ask her I
would meet up with her and um
I don't know if I found out if I found
out that I was adopted
and uh well that's not a fair game to
play because I would never know what
that void feels like you could only try
and
guess what it feels like yep that's it
I'm done with this that's what I would
do I would I would ask her I would go to
her
um
I mean I think she said she didn't want
any contact with you I'm guessing that
that's what she said in 1971.
I imagine
I would think if I ever did something
like that I would not want to know that
you're okay and yet you're happy and
that your life worked out
and I'd wanted the opportunity to say
sorry that's what I would want
um this makes me sad
um good luck with that dude I'm sorry
that that's going on I'm happy that they
let you
um
find out about your life there you know
it's funny is the amount of people that
aren't in your situation that aren't
adopted kids that are going to chime in
and start saying this is what it
shouldn't do it just causes more pip
it's like hey this isn't your [__]
thing
shut up
um
anyway all right that is the podcast
everybody I hope I'm just hoping that
this [__] thing
is gonna uh I'll be able to splice this
thing together oh my God am I am I being
meta I was just meta I know what I mean
all right that's it go [__] yourselves
and I'll check in on you on Thursday